[Music]
the new Superman actor has been
confirmed Among Us becomes a series and
the release of Spider-Man beyond the
spider-verse is at risk this week
Hollywood is full of news that being
said there's also new info on Tron 3
Barbie a reboot of Spawn and there's a
new trailer for Five Nights at Freddy's
enjoy the Kino check news
serial killer meets Tron as has now been
announced the main actor from Netflix's
Dahmer monster the Jeffrey Dahmer story
joins the cast of Tron Ares some of you
may already know Evan Peters from other
Productions these include the series
mayor of East Town as well as American
Horror Story and various X-Men movies in
which he played Peter maximoth Peters is
already the second big name to join Tron
3 which will also star Jared Leto the
director is yoshim rone who was
previously in charge of films such as
Pirates of the Caribbean 5 dead men tell
no tales and Maleficent Mistress of evil
production on the science fiction sequel
is due to start as early as August so
more news on Tron Aries can be expected
soon
no fakery for Barbie Margot Robbie
insists on using her own body in
close-ups the actress revealed this in a
new interview with Fandango it was all
about the start of the Barbie trailer
the feet of the famous character get out
of her pink heels and just stay in the
same stretched position Margot Robbie
confirmed that these are indeed her feet
a bit of tape for the Footwear a pull to
hold on to and about eight attempts done
was the funny effect the well-known
Harley Quinn actress emphasized that in
her movies she usually does these
so-called inserts herself that is
detailed shots of hands feet and so on
can't stand seeing the finished film and
knowing that the body parts shown don't
actually belong to her Robbie is thus
rather an exception in Hollywood
typically so-called body doubles are
used for scenes in which the faces of
high-paid stars cannot be seen the new
Barbie movie with Margot Robbie and Ryan
Gosling is currently a big talking point
in Hollywood the entire project is
creating a real Barbie boom in Malibu
you will soon even have the chance to
spend the night in Barbie's dream house
all in pink of course after initial
doubts director Greta gerwig's film
Project has managed to convince a
growing number of movie fans to check
out the film at least since the first
trailers were released in addition to
the ironic yet affectionate treatment of
the cult figure the simultaneous
theatrical release with Christopher
Nolan's Oppenheimer on July 21 2023 is a
particular cause for amusement we can't
wait to see whether the premature praise
is Justified
the new Superman has been chosen fans
have been eagerly awaiting the
announcement of who will succeed Henry
Cavill as the man of steel now James
Gunn announced not only the new cast of
Clark Kent but also the cast of Lois
Lane the choice for the role of the
iconic superhero ultimately fell on
David Coreen sweat who has already been
on the short list before the 29 year old
hasn't really been seen in big
Blockbusters so far in addition to a few
roles in the series like the politician
in Hollywood he most recently made an
appearance in the horror film hurl
better known might actually be the new
Lois Lane played by Rachel Brosnahan she
has appeared primarily as the title
character in the hit series The
Marvelous Mrs maisel but has also made
appearances in House of Cards and was in
front of the camera alongside Benedict
Cumberbatch for The Courier the casting
of David Koren sweat as Clark Kent and
Rachel Brosnahan as Lois Lane in
Superman Legacy ends months of guesswork
about the new faces of the famous
characters most are sure that they will
have a very hard time taking on the
legacy of their predecessors especially
of Henry Cavill as the previous Superman
in the Man of Steel Batman vs Superman
and Justice League movies we'll see how
they do when Superman Legacy hits
theaters on July 11 2025 at the latest
what do you think of the cast can you
imagine the two actors in The Familiar
roles or would you have preferred a
different cast let us know in the
comments
the video game hit Among Us is taking
the next step the cult game is now to be
released as a series according to an
exclusive report from variety the
developer studio innerslaw is working
with CBS eye animation Productions to
turn the game into an animated series
The Among Us series is of course based
on the concept of the game the crew of a
spaceship is infiltrated by an alien
shapeshifter who causes confusion
sabotages the ship and wants to kill
everyone the question is will the crew
succeed in hunting down the so-called
imposter or will his diabolical plan
work the series is being produced by the
animation studio titmouse titmouse is
best known for its series big mouth and
Star Trek lower decks the main character
is Owen Dennis who previously worked on
the Cartoon Network series Infinity
train at this time it is not known which
network or streaming service will show
Among Us with the talks currently
ongoing the game Among Us was first
released in 2018 and experienced a
massive surge in popularity in 2020
topping download charts almost
everywhere in the fourth quarter of 2020
the game had nearly 500 million monthly
active users over 4 billion views on
YouTube and more than 1.22 billion
sessions on Twitch many fans are
certainly excited to see how the popular
game will do as a series as soon as more
details and a possible release date for
the Among Us series are known we will
let you know of course
[Music]
Straight From Hell comic book hero spawn
returns to the big screen Bloom house
boss Jason Bloom talked in an interview
with comicbook.com about the development
of the new movie and already dared to
make a release date prediction spawn is
a successful comic series that has been
around since the early 90s it is about
the soldier and assassin Al Simmons who
was murdered and negotiates a deal with
a ruler of hell to come back to earth
from then on he pursues his revenge as a
hellspawn and fights criminals as well
as creatures from Hell the comic book
series was already made into a film back
in 1997 and although it was a financial
success it was not particularly well
received by critics Advance according to
producer Jason Bloom the reboot is
currently being worked upon very
actively and the aim is for a theatrical
release in 2025 whether this can be
adhered to depends very much on how long
the writer strike in the U.S continues
Todd McFarlane the creator of the comic
is to direct the movie for the leading
role Django Unchained actor Jamie Foxx
has been talks for years we will inform
you as soon as further information about
the reboot of Spawn is available
it's looking pretty bad for the release
of Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse
Sony insiders believe that the across
the spider-verse sequel will not be able
to meet its current release date as
there are far too many issues behind the
scenes officially the third movie is
supposed to be released on March 29 2024
which is only about 10 months after the
second part that seemed realistic at
first since both movies were originally
planned as one big story however we have
already expressed our concerns about the
release in our movie preview for beyond
the spiderverse after all spider Gwen
Boyce actress Hayley Steinfeld has not
recorded a single line of dialogue for
the third movie so far for part 2 voice
recordings already started four years
prior according to a report from vulture
Sony insiders have now spoken out about
the alleged production chaos the time
pressure was already significant for
part two and up until the end there were
always requests for changes from the
responsible parties the heavy workload
already caused more than 100 employees
to throw in the towel early on across
the spiderverse one artist says that
everyone focused entirely on the
finishing of part two which barely
worked out apart from a couple of
rehearsal sequences nothing was done on
beyond the spiderverse the whole time
their conclusion is that the current
release date is impossible to keep
considering the sheer amount of work
behind the animated adventure and these
latest reports we can probably consider
ourselves lucky if the movie is actually
released in 2024 at the moment these are
not official details of course we will
keep you posted if the March 29 2024
release date does indeed fall through
and Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse
is rescheduled
the trailer for The Five Nights at
Freddy's movie is here it is causing a
storm of enthusiasm the horror franchise
is especially popular with young fans
but it is uncertain whether they will
even be allowed to see the movie in
theaters at the moment The Joy about the
trailer still prevails
of course fans of the games about Freddy
Fazbear are eager to see the movie
Follow the original as closely as
possible fortunately the new trailer
already contains numerous details and
Five Nights at Freddy's Easter eggs that
will make fans happy for example the
so-called Toreador march song can be
heard when the surveillance cameras
start going crazy the same music that is
heard in the game every time the lights
go out
can also see the character Bonnie in the
Supply Closet in the game that's indeed
the only character that can appear there
moreover the appearance of spring Bonnie
in particular causes a lot of talk among
fans Bill and William Afton uses it in
the game to kill his enemies
speaking of William Afton the Five
Nights at Freddy's trailer also hints at
some differences from the game for
example the villain hides behind the
fake name Dave Miller co-owner of the
pizzeria in the trailer however it seems
to be a man named Steve Ragland possibly
a false Trail for those who know the
game wild speculations also revolve
around the age rating of The Five Nights
at Freddy's movie while some assume a
PG-13 in the U.S others even talk about
a possible R rating however at this time
there is actually still no age rating so
younger fans still have to worry whether
they will be able to see the film in
cinemas the release is coming soon Five
Nights at Freddy's will hit theaters on
October 27 2023.
that was this week's news what are your
thoughts on the new Superman and do you
think Among Us can succeed as an
animated series we are interested in
your opinion if you want to know more
about Spider-Man make sure to check out
our previously mentioned movie preview
of beyond the spiderverse and should you
not be very familiar with the Spider-Man
comics our movie preview of Madam Webb
is sure to surprise you thanks for
watching and see you next week for more
kenocheck news
[Music]
thank you